success car yashka some sabasha true hey
Natasha
you didn't rush for geology to suck
coach cool battle game you need to get
up and you need to keep running and you
need to keep going is one of the most
important critical lessons ever and they
save you tear gruel you can do anything
you want to do you can do anything you
want to do and then as soon as you go to
class you tell them what you want to do
and it I met what make you think you're
gonna do something like that man crazy
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent adds something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message get up and start
running over you Gore Gopal das AB given
me Jay Haas munakata average even me
success prop karna chaja taeho
two-minute Carney party air Drita's
Aegina part ahead determination sadena
part a peerage rakhna Parata patient
banana papa
aurilla bean sub capelin Hikaru table
pick a barge even match no TRPA
challenges appear on fellow Japan from
gurjot ahead order
success Kokoschka sabzi Basha true Henny
Russia led near a few Java support Koba
Togepi - Oh Jonah
Tobi's Madeira voyage Carolina yamadera
apne Pacheco John de pierre sumata
cherub review chiotti arrow Bachar you
chase it Georgia German / Gaddafi
Oh Jesse bechara semana Capretta Karthik
Mecca hog area takuma Pacheco Pavarotti
a horse Koh bon jour zealot Marty a
total package Akaka your gear data or
pass amplitude would do barakatuh karna
caprara Carter / Mouse keep Erica creepy
Tabarrok pourcel at might be a butcher
some magenta
he did Micucci La Coruna to lock a para
una pareja Affleck but any conjure pero
/ today nanika present retire after
mature doe barometer school at mawr PA
dr. gira japan poor sahaja tacky edema
character Haruna Tobi's Lockhart
irritable a giraffe kabocha tgzip--
agnya prepare part of i'ma apni baat
Chico to TA Alexander da Madeira believe
at Ajanta a cage angle may become car
pursue a shell lumely te George at
pranayamas Barajas on declare pain or
Madeira to be cheeky sod she shook Assad
a missionary
bah-bah-bah heartily giotto's particular
shop on Kerrigan easily subsequently
Jessica Jennifer Roscoe not Marty a the
cuteness he he do bar alot mafia kakuzu
you sneaky yo crea hey Audra hey do bar
alot Marty a [ __ ] cable attorney Dorna
prora McCray Jeevan metal bar - Nokia I
challenges tiny home giving a home
failed only liquid majira escape but
check we are
jab it remotely my job be challenges I
chick me Barbie Avira which Nancy cook
was but Jason Ignacio would kick a
dilemma saku kara naked hog messy cook a
girl cookie kurohagi avinasi cookie
table yes success in Chile punching
Shikarpur Vanessa :
what I love about Gorgo Paul does is he
takes these timeless truths these pieces
of wisdom and he puts them together
always in this amazing story that just
makes sense and this is one of those
pieces of advice that every entrepreneur
really needs to understand because life
will kick you in the face because no
matter how great an idea you have when
you get started you will fail a lot it's
a story of every successful entrepreneur
they failed they failed they failed they
failed and then they won people will
laugh at you your bank account will run
out you will have parents and friends
and family who will not support you and
your endeavors you will delt yourself
you will have a voice on your shoulder
saying you can't do this you don't have
the money the resources of the talent
who are you to think you can go off and
do this big thing you'll have lots of
these moments in your life as you try to
build this business up and remembering
that you need to get up and you need to
keep running and you need to keep going
is one of the most important critical
lessons ever now the question that
becomes how do you do it you know you
are in the hole you are sunk you've just
been hit in the face not by a giraffe
but by life some major setback how do
you get up you know you need to get up
but you may not have the baby giraffe
instinct so how do you actually get up
and keep going I use regret my specific
tactic is I use regret because the pain
that you're feeling right now is real
the pain of rejection the pain of losing
is real it hurts I just make the future
pain so much bigger because what's the
alternative
if you don't keep going with your
business your idea your dream what's the
alternative you go back to a life that
you don't like you go back to a job that
you don't want to work at you go back to
working with people you don't want to be
around you go back to doing work that is
beneath you you don't want that life and
that may seem a little bit painful if
you look at a one-week time for
or one month timeframe I make that a 50
year time frame
I imagine this crappy life that I'm
gonna have to live for the next 50 years
of my life and how painful that's gonna
be and that gives me the courage to get
up and go off and do the things that I
need to do and so I face a situation
lots of times over my career but the
most painful one is with my first
business when I was 19 years old and my
business was struggling and I sucked and
I was putting in tons of effort tons of
time and I told my business partner that
I quit and it was the worst day of my
life I had a brutal time trying to sleep
that night
and I woke up the next day and I just
imagined my life going back to working
at some company doing the work that I
didn't want to do and I said I can't
quit on this company I need to keep
going I need to see this through I'm
okay with the whole thing falling apart
and failing but I'm not okay with not
knowing I'm not okay with me not feeling
like I gave it my all
I cannot live the rest of my life in
regret wishing that I had given it more
in this very moment and so I got up that
next day and I went back to my business
partner I said I'm still in if you'll
take me and luckily he did and we we
continued on we built the business so
step one is when you feel like life is
kicking in the face and you've got a big
loss on you that you need to get up and
keep going
and the specific path that I use it
really helps is through regret just
imagine how crappy life would be for the
rest of your life if you do not give
your dream your very best make that so
painful and hopefully it forces you to
take action get up and keep running now
have a really special bonus clip for you
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know how do you deal with life
kicking you in the face when there's a
major setback you take a major loss what
do you do to help get you back up and
keep going I would love to know
personally but I think it's also gonna
help everybody else watching who might
be in a hole right now and could use
your advice so please leave it down in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever
your one word is much love I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
this man began singing and playing the
guitar at aged four his parents didn't
want him to watch too much television he
was banned from playing video games but
he had a lot of books about art he
didn't enjoy school and was even bullied
at age 15 a year later he decided to
quit school and follow his dreams of
making in the music industry now things
didn't go as planned
he ended up homeless sleeping often on
trains just to get by this lasted for
around three years where he had nowhere
to live
he spent multiple nights and days
performing to small groups often without
even eating
to his surprise some of his tracks went
viral on iTunes even reaching the
number-two spot on the iTunes chart by
the end of the year his album had sold
800 and 1000 copies making it the eighth
best-selling album of the year
his latest song was one of the most
listened to worldwide his name ed
Sheeran today he's mentored by Elton
John Paul McCartney says that he's a fan
he's even written songs for Taylor Swift
in one direction and many many more edie
story teaches us that there's no such
thing as an overnight success he was so
shocked and surprised when his album
went viral online but when you look at
the struggle before that we see the pain
he had to go through often we only view
people's success as what we see in their
highlight reel and we forget what they
actually had to go through to get to
that stage and that's why the next time
you see someone that you think is
successful don't focus on what they're
doing now focus on what they did to get
them when you young and your kid you
have so many I grew up in the hood man
Oh Flint Michigan where I'm from and
they save you Tara cruise you can do
anything you want to do you can do
anything you want to do and then as soon
as you go to class you tell them what
you want to do and I met what makes you
think you're gonna do something like
that man crazy yeah and I said okay wait
which one is it now can I do it a kid
I'd do it what right right right so I
started to call people on that I started
to call people and I say you know what
I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna just try
something that I've never done before I
want to design furniture I want to be a
part of this thing that's what I'm going
and you know what happened that's not
work people started doing its it started
happening
we took this furniture to Milan which we
went in front of all the best people in
the whole world and it got accepted and
people were saying how great it was and
how beautiful it was and I said man
don't never let anybody talk you out of
something like that it never man never
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like it I am Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
throw Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access